Professor Edison Tse, nice to have you here
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Thank you. Yeah. Nice to talk to you here.
Thank you.
So, I've had the unique pleasure of being
in your class most recently at Stanford.
The masters in Management and Engineering.
MS&E 274.
And you're a world expert.
On your product management.
Thinking strategically about
entrepreneurial strategy.
The inventor of the
grabber-holder dynamics strategy.
And I'd love to spend these next 20 minutes
in sort of peeking your brain.
And trying to consolidate some of
what we've learned over the past 10 weeks.
It's gonna be an impossible feat.
But we'll try as much as we can.
So, can you just start telling me
a little bit about yourself.
How did you even get to this
incredible incredible industry?
Okay.
Well, I'm starting a little bit about myself.
I'm actually a, my training is electric engineering.
So, I got a PhD in Electric Engineering from MIT.
So, my area's actually in System and Control.
And I've been a doing a lot of work in the area.
Getting some awards and things like that.
But, I'm sort of start interested in something.
I wanna do the system in control.
They are all man-made. Right?
System things like that.
Well, I started in the system where
you have a lot of human.
A lot of people. Right?
So, I start to work in the industry
for many years.
And then I start coming back to Stanford.
But going actually not to
Electric Engineering Department.
But going into beginning is the
Engineering Economic Systems.
Where we are looking at systems
that are can be human system,
can be you know, it’s a combination of
human system and the engineering system.
So, it can be that it's an interaction of
all the system that make me do it.
And I'm also interested in some of the
economics as part of it.
So that’s how I get started.
Then to some work,
for example managing fisheries.
And some of the natural resources.
And things like that.
Well, I got also interested in business because
I got my ex-boss asked me
to join his company.
We started a company but I was faculty member.
So I say, "I can’t join the company."
Where were you already a faculty member?
At Stanford?
Yeah. I was a faculty at Stanford.
And so, I said, "I would not be able to join the company."
But he said,
"Well you don’t have to join the company.
Well you can be a consultant. Right?"
And so, to be a consultant.
To be a co-founder.
As a consultant.
And I say, "What? That's interesting. Go"
So, I get into it.
So, we build a company.
Which is in the very beginning,
it's actually Org company.
And the first wave of AI,
we're doing some of the work in there.
Okay.
So, it's a more technology-driven.
And we do a lot of technology work.
And things like that.
But I start yet because I was
I played a role as not only a consultant.
I was on the bot.
So, I got a start understanding on
what's happening in the business world.
The dynamics of an entrepreneur.
So that I got interested in entrepreneurship.
Part of it.
So, I was doing,
And then I come to Stanford
I still want to continue doing work at Stanford.
So, I start my interest.
My interest has shifted.
Because of that.
From a little bit of economics
and go into the business world.
That's how I get started.
Okay.
And in the very beginning my research
are more on the system part.
Where I was also looking at business
as an overall system.
Interesting.
So, thinking from the system point of view,
How the system point of view looking at
from the business organization. Right?
You're gonna think of system organization
really a system.
So, that the electrical engineer part of you
that's trying to scope business as another.
Yes. Yeah.
And then I knew that in engineering,
the engineer big thing and engineer as well
in control. It's feedback. Right?
Feedback control is a big thing.
But the feedback control is always
you try to stabilize the system.
But I said, "Well, if you look at the business,
you actually don’t want to be
stabilizing the system.
You want to un-stabilize the system.
Because you wanna grow. Right?
Grow is not stabilizing.
So, what I'm saying that actually in business
what you need is not negative feedback.
You want positive feedback.
So that's the whole concept.
Of what Ecom is.
So, what is the passive feedback?
A positive feedback is something
that excites you.
And then you have something supporting you.
And then you create a exponential growth.
That's where from the engineering point of view.
And so, you know I'm very curious about
this grabber-holder dynamics.
Which we've talked about extensively
over the past 10 weeks.
And I think it's fascinating how it defines
so much of also what we're seeing now.
You know covid has taken over.
And a lot of what I'm seeing now in the way
the companies are approaching this.
And a lot of the innovations
that are coming about.
I keep trying to classify them.
How are they strategizing
and positioning themselves within this
grabber-holder dynamics.
So, could you give us a slight introduction
into what is this dynamic
that is not so popular?
Right.
So, how do you create a positive dynamic?
The behavior of course of dynamic
from the engineering term is that
you are creating eigenvalue was positive,
in some way.
That is from a mathematical point of view.
But how do you translate that
into the business point of view.
I say it must be something that solve
in largely for that.
It was something that [--]
So, what you wanna do is that your business,
you're gonna grab it.
You're gonna go excited in a certain way.
And then you're gonna find something to hold it.
And that's how the grabber-holding come along.
And one of the disruption is that
there are forces that sort of creating new forces
that could kick you in a certain direction.
Right? It's a huge force.
So, what you can do using
a grabber-holder dynamics is
you can think of all those forces
like whatever. Right?
They are actually,
they’re pushing you at a certain direction.
But it will not stay there.
Because when the forces go away, you fall back.
But if you're gonna hold it.
Then you create a new situation.
So, I'm saying for example,
you take the covid situation
the covid situation actually are
are sort of that kick you
in a certain so that you shifted your preference.
Shift it your way like what is the right way
of doing things.
And sometimes, it may allow you
to create a different kind of a value structure.
For example, a lot of people find that
because of this covid-19. Right?
People actually find new value in family.
They revisit the value of family.
They revisit the value of community.
Right.
Which they have lost.
You know.
They're too busy. They lost it.
But then, in order for that to sustain,
that means that if you can have something
that hold it,
then it become,
even that the covid-19 is gone,
you still have this value let's say sustaining.
The question is,
What are those thing you need to build up
so that you can support it? Right?
The way you're saying is that,
the way that the grabbing works is sort of like
a kick in the stomach.
And okay we're shifting
the consumer behavior in one way.
Whether it's an invention.
Or if it's a global pandemic.
Exactly.
And we've attained this new behavior.
We've shifted.
The consumers have shifted the mindset,
the values, their desires, etc.
Now the question is,
How do we hold or retain these values?
Retain that. Because if you could not retain it,
then we'll bounce it back.
Right.
So, a good case for this would be,
well so, Zoom for example enjoyed a lot
of this new type of consumer interaction.
And a lot of people are wondering.
Well now things are starting to open up again.
And hopefully soon everything will open up.
And are we retaining this consumer behavior?
Exactly.
or virtual conflict,
For example, if Zoom can do something
to make you feel that even you're back
to normal life, you still find new value in there.
And then if I can build certain thing
that allows that, that's what I called a holder.
And so, the holder is something you build
afterwards.
After you see what the grabber is pushing you.
So, building the holder is more like you know,
you do it in time.
It's not something that you can foresee.
So, you just have to play along.
It's more adaptive.
It is more, you know you have to build up
as you go on.
That's the whole concept. Right?
So, what are some examples
of grabber-holder dynamics that we
can see over the past, I don’t know,
half a century for example?
Well, there's a lot.
Almost everything is sort of,
like you start to have a grabber
and then you start having a holder.
I give a few sort of example. Right?
You know for example,
we're talking about PC, right?
PC is a typical grabber-holder dynamic concept.
Right?
The idea is that I'm gonna have a computer
for everybody.
So, sounds like a great idea.
Okay. And suddenly, in the beginning
nobody knows what that does mean. Right?
Just, they know what's a computer. Right?
They know a little bit about computer.
They know the main frame.
Just do a lot of calculation.
That's too complicated.
Too big things. Right?
Too many things.
Right.
And if you ask them what is V-dot
and nobody knows. Right?
So, in the very beginning,
you see what a computer is,
it's a little box that can do a calculation.
And then some time when you turn off
the electricity, everything is gone. Right?
That is, oh wow, that's not good. Right?
So, it's exciting.
I can use that to make calculation.
But all the calculation that I make it's all gone.
That's were in the very beginning.
The first PC doesn’t have a memory.
Interesting.
Okay. So, what did they do?
They attached a recorder.
Tape recorder.
Like a regular tape recorder attached to a PC.
So that you can record [--]
But then you have the search rules.
It's very complicated. Right?
And that's why they get good at least tried, right?
That's where I comes in because
they see a need that I have to do
all the computation or I'm gonna put it.
Right?
We know that the big computer they can do it.
But when you're little box,
you say personal computer,
I saw small,
should I have it or not?
Nobody know in the very beginning.
So, sort of trial and errors.
And you may say that the first success
of Apple too is because
they attached to it with this drive.
Okay. Okay.
Was that the whole perspective of it?
That's the whole perspective.
And you know this. Right?
People find you near this right.
Well, also you need to have some
computation or two.
Because it's your computer.
You know no one is gonna do
write the programming.
And at that time, Apple too become successful.
It's mainly because,
then there were star,
And the vesicle comes in.
That allow you to do while processing,
have a letter
and things like that.
Vesicle allow you to do
simple calculation and accounting.
And that's being successful.
And that's the holder. Right?
Definitely.
Okay.
So, you have that example
and I'd love to talk also about retail.
And that specifically I'm interested
because that was my--
I give you a very interesting example. Right.
yeah. Please.
Okay. The other interesting example is Alibaba.
Okay. Yeah.
Very relevant. Yes.
Okay.
Now, Alibaba was started of,
Alibaba start fooling around in the net.
But in the very beginning,
they are helping American firm
to source a product in China.
That's how they do it. Right?
It's more like a B2B. Right?
They're sourcing.
They're helping you.
Actually they're not helping you to source.
You just go in and find information.
Okay, you want a visor and thing.
I can tell who are the manufacturer.
That's they start in the very beginning.
Okay?
That means they keep going wrong.
Okay.
Then Amazon started in the US.
And sort of E-commerce has start in the US.
And they are successful.
An e-commerce and
And eBay they all come go to China.
And want to do it in China.
Then Alibaba say,
"Wow. I can do that too." Right?
You know, sort of similar thing.
And maybe I should also set up
something like this.
Okay.
But on the other hand.
One of the things is that,
if you want to do e-commerce,
Right? So, what is a holder?
What is the holder?
What is the holder, right?
One is that,
Why would people want
to come to the computer to buy thing?
Is that the normal thing that people do?
No. The answer is no. Yeah.
Maybe some young kids would try.
Back then it wasn’t right.
Yeah. At that time. Right?
Maybe some young kid would try it.
Everybody has computer in China.
Right. Okay.
So, where's the holder? Right?
The holder is that you need to have a computer
or that somebody need to have that computer.
But on the other hand,
Also, what you need is that
how are you gonna pay?
Okay? Right.
And the third is that
how I trust you.
You know, why do I wanna buy it in there?
Because if I buy some anything,
it's not useful,
then what? Right?
Yeah.
In US, you know
this becomes take off for several reason.
I think the holder is there.
Okay, in the US,
how do you solve the problem of payment?
Well you can have credit card.
You can scan your credit card or whatever.
Even there are PayPal,
but they start off with credit card.
So, people can pay thru credit card.
Right.
So, I solved the problem of payment.
Well, how do I trust it?
Well in US they have the consumer protection.
US have very high consumer protection.
So that if you don't like it,
you can return it.
Yup. Okay.
Then you have to accept the return then.
So, that means that in the US the holder is there.
Right. Okay?
But Professor, it sounds also that
from a lot of people--
But in China it's not there
Yeah.
So, it sounds that in order for a company
like eBay or Amazon to become a holder
of this new user experience they were helped by,
They need to deal with the two problem. Right?
And they didn’t deal with them on their own.
They had the government
and the payment system deal with them
for them. Right?
They didn’t do this on their own.
Because that means that the US
all have already the infrastructure.
Right.
That allow you to do it.
And that sometime people can return.
But in China,
in developing countries sometimes
they give a term called Institutional Void.
There's some institutional void.
And that's exactly what happened in China.
There's institutional void in China.
The credit card system.
There's no credit ranking system.
There's more wreck in credit assessment system.
So, there's not a lot of credit card [--].
Most of the credit card is [--]
in China are all those
very famous millionaires.
Right? Sure.
But young people they will not have one. Right?
But all the rich people in China
they're not gonna buy thing on themselves.
On their own.
So then they are not the shopper.
So they have the credit card.
But they are not the shopper.
The shopper are the one who didn’t really
have the credit card.
So it sounds also when you talk about timing,
how timing is important for a startup
or for any entrepreneur.
Exactly.
You have a load of situation over there. Right?
So, the other thing is that
it is trust problem.
Because in China if you buy certain thing,
if you don’t like it, you cannot return it.
Okay?
People will not return it.
And they will not accept it.
And there's no law to protect you.
Okay? So, you cannot sue them or whatever.
You cannot do that.
So, therefore how do you solve that problem?
And this is how Alibaba becomes successful.
So, how do they solve it?
How do they solve it?
Okay. The way they solve it is to say
we're build up something called escrow system.
Like US they have escrow system.
What escrow system is that,
you buy certain thing,
a certain amount you pay into Alibaba.
Alibaba will gonna be the escrow,
they gonna hold it.
They are not gonna release it to the seller.
And then they tell the seller that the buyer
have already paid and you can ship it to him.
Right. Okay?
And they ship it to the buyer.
And the buyer have seven days to see,
to examine the thing.
And within seven days,
they can return it to Alibaba.
And Alibaba will ship it back to the seller.
And return the money back to the buyer.
So that means that they are the middle man
that keep track on that. Right?
That's a lot of logistics to solve
the certain problem.
There's a lot of logistics to do. right?
Not only that.
They say no fee.
No fee.
So, that means that if you return,
doesn’t cost you anything.
Interesting.
So that obviously is very--
So, an Amazon it's different.
Because you actually pay in advance.
You already pay for the product.
But you have so much trust in the system.
That you know you can just return it.
Right? Two things.
Because in the credit card system,
if you don’t like it,
you can complain to the credit card
and credit card gonna report it.
But you know that's interesting.
That's already start up in the US. Right?
And then you have platform like Upwork,
which is for freelancers,
where you actually keep the money in escrow,
it's all virtual.
There’s no tangible services.
It's all hypothetical work to be done.
Like please put in data.
Do a research project for me.
Not that I would ever do that for the Stanford
of course.
But then,
once I put the money in escrow,
The freelancer can perform the work.
And only once I'm satisfied.
The money gets released.
Which leaves room for negotiation.
Because it's so subjective on what are the goods.
And you're quality of the goods.
That's exactly what's happening. Right?
So, that's exactly what Alibaba did.
But I think the interesting part
what they did is that I charged it free.
Then you say,
Why are they keeping the money?
Here's an interesting part.
The seven day where the money is in Alibaba,
he would put it into the money market.
And earns of interest.
And that's how they pay for it.
This is in a gray area. Right?
Because it's not your money.
Right. Yeah?
It's not your money.
But then if you have a lot of money coming in,
then you can become at par.
But then they very quickly shift it
into set up another thing called
an extra money account.
That means that I can put money in there
and the money would be used for helping you.
I would make them interest for you.
And they keep a little bit.
And anytime you want to buy thing
you can use that money.
So, they solve the problem very quickly.
After a while.
So, they use a gray area to move in. Okay?
So that's the part they solve that holder.
But there's another great holder.
It's very important.
it's why would people buy thing on the internet?
Okay?
Now, it turns out that if you look at the timing,
it turns out they start taking off in year 2003.
Okay.
What is the significant of that?
In year 2003,
SARS appear in China.
Like a covid-19.
Because of SARS, many place are in lockdown.
Especially in Beijing.
And then our people still have to buy thing.
What do they do?
They go to the internet.
I love it. Okay?
Now, whether without that
that will happen or not, I don’t know.
Because history didn’t tell us.
I mean, I cannot run back the history.
But I can say that it has something to do with it
because it helped to change
people’s preference in buying.
o, that's why I'm talking in to you guys
that in covid-19,
we have a lot of things gonna happen.
If you learn from the Alibaba example.
That means that the’re new things
that gonna open up.
If you can see what its leading to.
And there's actually,
There's another company called JayD.
It's actually that company
JayD started of is that he is only a,
he have a retail store
selling electronic equipment in Beijing.
And because of SARS,
he actually moved that into the internet.
That means that there are
certainly something that are happening there.
JayD is now one of the largest
e-commerce in China.
It's unbelievable.
And Jack Ma's story aside from all that
is just so phenomenal by itself.
And I think what's really really incredible
and very reflective on what we’ve done
over these past 10 weeks is that
understanding how dynamic this world is.
And how is an entrepreneur,
You can have an amazing idea
with amazing execution.
But if you're not dynamic,
And if you're not thinking about market forces,
and how everything is changing,
then you're not setting yourself off for success.
And especially today,
with things changing so fast.
I just heard a podcast that
Instacart, the grocery shopping application,
they've reached their financial milestone
that they predicted for 2024.
Now you would think that in 2020 would
so many smart people working
on this billion-dollar company,
they’d be able to predict their sales over years.
And it just shows how something happens
to the world, markets shift, consumers shift.
Who would have guess that
they would have had a three-year
or four years advancement
in just a matter of weeks.
I can’t believe our time is almost up
and Professor I know you have
to go to your next meeting already.
But I have to leave with one last question.
Three words that you would best
describe yourself.
Or any of your colleagues at Stanford
would describe you as.
Well, I don’t know.
The hardest question.
The hardest questions.
I think that,
I would like to,
my interest, my desire
is to,
three things right.
I feel that entrepreneur is culture dependent.
Okay?
In different parts of the world.
You have a different kind
of entrepreneur activity,
a different kind of innovation.
And so, the innovation are cultural dependent.
So, that means that whatever,
And each part of the world with
culture background they have actually
different compatible advantage
in deriving certain type of innovation.
And so, I believe that people should collaborate.
Worldwide collaboration and innovation.
I think the past in this part.
And the whole idea that innovation
is creating value to the world.
And so, maybe I would like to describe me
as like to promote global innovation
to increase the wellbeing,
or livelihood of everybody in the world.
I love it so much.
Professor, thank you so much for your time--
I think I'm more than three words.
I'll take because it was just too inspiring.
Professor, thank you for the last 10 weeks.
Thank you for teaching us all about
dynamic entrepreneurial strategy
and I look forward to taking
more classes with you.
Okay. Great. I’ll see you.
Take care. Bye.